and that's why I knew she is a witch and
so is mom and so am i hey Marnie Piper
it's been a long time since she took us
to a magical world full of awesome
spooky creatures Halloweentown and its
sequels are some of our favorite
Halloween movies we still love watching
you save the town with your witty
abilities but we have noticed a few
things we never picked up on his kid and
some of these things have a seriously
scratching our heads the Halloween town
franchise is one of Disney Channel's
most successful movie series ever from
jokes to plot holes to a few offensive
moments there are several things that
only adults would understand keep
watching to find out why calibers
actions weren't exactly uncalled for
[Music]
Shakespeare is that you Disney Channel
was probably the last place you would
expect to see a Shakespeare reference
but there is a quote from Macbeth
that is totally associated with
Halloween double double toil and trouble
fire burn and cauldron bubble is dead by
shakespeare's witches take a look at
this witch microwave from Halloween town
what are these microwaves having to even
do how do you heat up your breakfast
with toil and trouble losing their heads
Halloween town might seem like a perfect
place to live but if you rewatch this
franchise as an adult you'll probably
notice that some things aren't ideal
Aggies friend says in the first movie
yeah that's right it's a shelter for
people who don't have heads why are
there so many headless people that they
require a shelter there's also the fact
that Aggies friend is baking them
muffins which the headless people can't
eat not our Marnie Marnie was such a
hero to kids in the late 1990s and early
2000s she really made the movies what
they are today
Kimberly J Brown will forever be
associated with the first three
Halloween town movies but in 2006 Disney
Channel decided to make a fourth film
and Kimberly wasn't available so they
recast morning sara paxton is a great
actress but she was nothing like the
original Marnie this left a lot of fans
wondering what the Disney Channel was
thinking worst clue ever and
Halloween Town two calibers revenge
Calabar son steals Aggies spell book he
cast the grace spell which turns
Halloween town residents into mundane
humans they spend the whole movie trying
to reverse this spell but the key to
doing it is way too easy
apparently all mining has to do is say
traffic that's the word apart backwards
it's one word in part of his cell and
all she has to do is say it backwards
it's an epic movie but that part was
more than a little cheesy where'd he go
Halloween town is full of ghosts and
goblins you might expect to have a
character totally disappear from a scene
but you wouldn't expect having a major
actor disappear from the whole franchise
Luke Marni's goblin friend was a huge
part of the first two movies and let's
be honest we all shipped to Marnie and
Luke together but Luke is completely
absent from the third movie Halloween
Town High the movie offers no
explanation for this absence we want to
know what happened to Luke a Hollywood
legend our parents probably noticed this
even though we didn't Aggie isn't just a
super cool grandma she's played by
Hollywood legend Debbie Reynolds her
acting career lasted almost 70 years
before she passed away she won a ton of
awards for all she did she was also the
mother of Carrie Fisher who played
Princess Leia in Star Wars it is super
cool that someone so famous was on
Halloween town useless magic
Marni's little brother Dylan is one of
our favorite characters he is always the
voice of reason in the movies powers
he's ahead of his time by being super
devoted to caring for the environment
Dylan is shown to have some magical
powers at the end of the first movie his
fingertips start having magical static
but Dylan never uses his power in the
rest of the films we don't understand
why and he never explained it if we had
magical abilities we would use them for
everything
trendy Halloween magazine watching
Halloween town as an adult is really fun
there are so many tiny details we never
picked up on his kids the people who
created the sets and props were really
creative one of the funniest hidden
jokes is in a magazine one of the
Halloween town residents is sitting on a
park bench reading the cover says Sam
pher this is meant to be like the trendy
fashion magazine of Vanity Fair the
covers even look similar this joke was
definitely snuck in there to make the
adults chuckle that's not witchcraft
Disney Channel is really great when it
comes to creating movies their viewers
can relate to but in the first
Halloweentown movie a joke made it into
the final cut that was offensive to some
people
Marnie puts on a witch's hat and says
Wicca is a religion that uses nature and
magic in its practice many Wiccans hate
being called witches but Marnie called
the type of witches we see at Halloween
by the name of this religion we are sure
this made many people who practice that
religion very uncomfortable he's got a
point okay we totally understand that
Calabar was evil he hated humans and
wanted to take an army of ghouls and
goblins into the mortal world but he
also has a point
the residents of Halloweentown are
forced to stay in a totally separate
dimension but the mortal world used to
be their home they're no longer evil
monsters who want to harm humans why
should they have to stay isolated from
their original home which of the
Halloweentown movies is your favorite
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching be sure to like this video and
subscribe to the things for more awesome
content we'll catch you later
[Music]